i'm i have this feeling we're
about oh what is that upset
let's jump into the the matchups of today we've
got sardosha niko up first to start off we know
that uh sardoche has been crushing it right
the guy is non-stop right now what are your
thoughts on how he's established himself maybe
as an early favorite and what's gonna happen
here today in his first matchup with nico he's
really just doing chess all the time and um
and it's it's going to be interesting to see uh
see how he fares because he's probably the clear
favorite at the moment there's one thing that i
think nico deserves a lot of credit for is she was
uh she was streaming chess before any
of the before this boom ever occurred
i remember i was actually playing grand chess
tour event in india in november of 2019 and she
was playing chess so it's it's really great to
see her competing in pogchamps 3. yeah i totally
agree she was one of the first people streaming
chess before before it was cool to stream chess
right and so it's pretty awesome and who knew we
would say that it's it's now cool to stream chess
that's true yeah no i mean sarah dosh has been
just insane on on the chest so uh it's great
see now he plays the h4 which i actually don't
like i really don't like h4 because now there's
like knight c6 and knight a5 and i think
i think nico's has a great position so far
i agree she's she's developed developed quickly
and with the king safe i'm with you that h4 while
you'd love to i have an idea of an h-file attack
it doesn't quite line up that sardocis put his
pieces on the queen side and going for h4 wow now
he's playing e4 leaving his king in the center
this is very explosive i mean black is actually
much better here i don't think neo will play pawn
takes pawn in knight a5 but just just basically
attacking the center i mean this is very scary
for sardosh already this is uh wow this is great
great great start for niko oh man i'm so nervous
already it's the first game god i gotta calm down
i mean this is this is a great start though this
is a great start because i mean i think everyone
expects sort of should be a favorite but i think
a lot of people are not expecting nico to um
i feel like she's actually underrated relative
to sarah dosh like queen enough eight is another
great move here we're gonna have an end game and
sardosha is an extra pawn but at the same time
when you look at the placement of the ponds it's
not so white's pawns are a little bit easier
to target than blacks pawns are so i think um
this is gonna be very interesting to see what
happens because i don't think i don't think any of
us expected nico to um to uh to put up this kind
of resistance then she has a pretty good position
i mean she is down a pawn but if down upon an end
game where there are no clear ideas for either
side you have to maneuver it's anyone's game yep
especially when she's the one up on the clock
right and i don't think sardosh expected her to
okay i mean he still has plenty of time but but if
if this disparity stays and she's up two minutes
when we're under time pressure that could decide
the game exactly yeah i know i mean this is
this is phenomenal this is uh yeah this is just
the start we wanted no six moves no throbbings
no no nothing just just good good clean shots
now look at that rook h2 he's he's uh he allows
the queen trade but with a defensive move
i feel like he's he's not happy with where
this is going given that he was all in on
the idea of checkmate he can't be thrilled
about the endgame great start solid chess
almost 70 000 viewers already just on twitch
alone welcome everybody hog champs is back
um i i have this feeling we're about
oh why does that sing about the scene
ah oh man well we have our we have our first
blunder um our first one it's only it's only a
night but it's only a night it's not it's not like
a queen or anything so it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's over like if sargeras just
takes upon an e6 and allows rook g1
but he castles which is very nice yeah that was
maybe the last chance the blunder was to take and
allow the skewer but he sees it and i and i think
these kind of moments here hikara are going to be
what separates sardosh if he does go on to have a
really good pog champs tournament because i think
he's put in enough time that once he's better
i'm going to guess he's he's not maybe once
he's winning i'm gonna guess he's not gonna
blow too many games and we'll see but but i
think that maybe she had her chance got a little
impatient with that night move um but i expect
sartosh to be able to to clean it up from here
okay king defau king d5 try to run back in okay
wait what is he doing okay i think actually you
know what sargeras is very smart here i think
he knows how to win this without worrying
about what's on the other side of the board
yep yeah okay he yeah i think he's pointed
to yeah he knows how he's just gonna
uh and that's a that's a human grandmaster thing
to do right you just go for what you know as a
win and you don't need to be you don't need to
play like the computer go for what you know so
that's again just his experience showing
again yeah and yeah as long as he finishes
yeah uh-oh okay okay and he sees it yeah very
nice by sardosh well it'll be fun to see what
opening she plays given the one lesson we had
and i don't know what else she's been working on
but i i hope she i hope she sticks with the fried
liver that was actually what we worked on in caro
yeah well i guess we'll see um so so we have
sir right and she plays f4 on move one wow
we worked on but it's okay all right
yeah so i would think here probably
i mean think where nico is you don't
really want to take the pawn but playing
a move like e4 here is good but i think
extremely difficult to find um wow though
okay okay that's actually very funny yeah
she e4 is a great move and she finds it
and probably the only real way yeah yeah strike
back here wow and now i mean i think the problem
is now now the rook on 86 is very good and the
knight on d4 is very good yeah knight on d4 is
good and it's also attacking the bishop on
d6 um the rook is attacking the bishop on
d6 oh oh no
oh she hung the bishop but she has a big
time advantage here she has a big time
um advantage g6 was a very nice move by
sarah dosh but man he is like he is he is
like all over the place it feels like pretty
soon his entire head's going to disappear
he's almost gone full thought yeah okay so
now will he see rook g2 here or not oh he does
wow wow and bish does he find bishop
oh my gosh yes yeah very nice yup
let's go let's go baby well let's let's let's wait
let's see if he can blunder here because again
he only has one pawn on the board that's true a
knight bishop mate oh knight takes h1 oh my gosh
he just blend oh my gosh he is he's not gonna
lose this game but i don't think he can i mean
uh yeah he's still gonna it's still probably gonna
be a draw he's gonna win the match i think but oh
that's uh not what you're not not what you were
hoping for i don't know how you do that i feel
like you have a sixth sense with the pogchamps
commentary like you knew the blunder was coming
and uh i i thought i thought he was about to show
that he was gonna convert it but there you go
i mean he is still winning here with
correct play but i it's just like a king d4
yeah if she runs her king to
the corner to go after the pawn
on h2 she's she's gonna draw this game i think
i agree agree with him oh man
yeah that is maybe the largest bottle of
dasani i've ever seen in my life by the way
that he just grabbed um all right
nico finds knight d2 you called it
hikaru she's good with the knights
and i think she's going to hold
yeah yeah so i mean sardosh is going to win
the match but i i think either either like
sardosh is like overrated or nico is um nico is
underrated that was very very good very very good
nico start start with you i know it maybe didn't
end the way you you wanted it to but playing one
of the stronger players you those games were
extremely good in fact you were better in both
of those games to start how did you feel about
about how you played and came out here today
i was a little upset because sardoshe is already
so good so i was like i get the hardest player
first but i also heard i think the biggest thing
i was intimidated about was that i heard that he
does really weird openings and really weird
like things and then i definitely saw that um
while we were playing i was like what is he
doing like he hasn't castled the whole game
like what is going on i know nothing about your
opening it was the first time i played against it
even though i played a lot of games recently
but well it was surprising or what you were
you were doing in early and i was so scared
and stressed i was like i was supposed to win
if you look at waiting but i was definitely in
struggle and well well paid for that honestly
i'm glad i was a good opponent against
you at least it wasn't too easy for you
so so sardoz you've been putting in a lot of
hours in the chest i think you did a 20 to 23
hour stream yesterday of only playing chess um
yeah i started like two weeks ago and i i've
been only playing chess for like two weeks yeah i
just obsessed yeah no i i think it's fantastic i
think certainly you're one of the favorites um
and actually nico i was looking at some of the
statistics and you've played a lot of blitz games
much more so than these 10-minute games with like
five minutes i think um and i was wondering if
that played a role in terms of why you were moving
so quickly because in both games you had a lot of
time on your clock um as as you were in the middle
part of the game and whether that was like just
duty or familiarity with playing quicker shots
i just have a thing where it's it's
really satisfying when i could think
quicker and like i feel like it also makes my
opponent nervous when they're i'm moving too
fast honestly when you were when you were doing
good moves in like tempo like playing instantly
i was like oh oh the [ __ ] is she playing so
well so fast so it was registering me and i i
think i i blundered a lot because of that i was
being like she's she isn't 800 that's not possible
oh thank you well congratulations to you
both uh for just being here we got we got
a long event ahead here two weeks sardoche
you're moving on there with the win and nico
you played super well i'm i'm i'm sure that
a lot of these other matches uh will have a
good chance to go your way so thank you both for
joining us and uh best of luck in your next round
you